johnny depp and amber heard five weeks
after johnny's defamation trial victory
amber wants the verdict thrown out
her lawyers are arguing that
he talked about the information that was
in the uk trial and the domestic
violence restraining order that she was
able to bring against him and he
referenced all of this but he wasn't
supposed to now this 10 million verdict
can be about something more than just
what's in this op-ed
amber's argument one there wasn't enough
evidence for johnny to win and two one
of the jurors wasn't properly vetted she
says there's a discrepancy between
documents provided to the court claiming
the juror was born in 1945 and public
records that showed the juror was born
in 1970 virginia law says that you
should check the identity of jurors but
that's not an actual law it's a
suggestion so the fact that that didn't
happen as unfortunate as that is for for
amber heard's team does not necessarily
mean that due process was violated this
arguably could affect kurds defense
because she was probably trying to get
rid of people who were kind of in the
age range of people that watched johnny
depp's movies
the appeal could take months but legal
analyst mitra hurian's opinion on if
amber has a chance in court with respect
to the juror's id not having been
verified it's very unlikely that that's
going to result in something that is a
potentially a mistrial or the verdict is
set aside i think at this point she has
lost so much credibility to the public
that it's going to be very hard for her
to bring any sort of claim or any sort
of
allegation or even you know say that she
was victimized even more i don't think
anyone's believing her at this point so
i think she just needs to put this to
bed
[Music]
you